[Music]
and watch your finger news submitted by
my phone died
hey Court has ruled that making a gun
like hand gesture is a crime
we're like this in Australia cause it's
probably actually dangerous there this
is a crime maybe this is a crime maybe
this is okay but this is a crime I think
I think this might be okay but if it's a
assault yeah and if you if you mind how
big the magazine is I think I'd be like
oh [ __ ]
this one huh will the assault one you
can only do one at a time though yeah
that's true are you love that concealed
gestures in our yeah like this yeah
I don't know these laws Pennsylvania a
court ruled that making a gun like hand
gesture is a crime after a man had made
the hand motion towards a neighbor a
threat it was during an argument with
the neighbor and apparently the like him
doing that gesture made a lot of
neighbors really really nervous
especially yeah right now - yeah that
makes the name is Steven Steve wow this
both ste PhDs that's Steven okay Steven
so it's ste V's my name nobody doesn't
with the pH and calls us Stefan I knew
that [ __ ] that's not legit listen I'm a
Steven and that [ __ ] that [ __ ] I added
that he's my famous thing you know he
can
[Laughter]
hurry
maybe the I know a basketball fans sure
I feel like the only for sure Steven is
the V yeah Steven never sure yet
don't take my name's we mean you you've
spelled with the PhD you can show you my
driver's license right now everyone
thinks I'm doing a bit but then you see
my address and be weird and [ __ ] no pull
up to your house yeah what about with
like Stephanie's like a Stephanie
Stephanie's PA it's always with the pH
and it's Steven e-mini you didn't
reading it so wrong I never Steve Annie
man I met a lot of stephenie's though
yeah I never met her Stephanie okay
anyway alright so I'm going to show you
guys the surveillance footage of this
threat the threat the neighbor the
sensitive watches all night like a
[ __ ] cowboy show down threat right
there with the sandals on that's the
death wish she looks like a get off get
off my lawn kind of guy right dude
single bear yeah would you get in
trouble if you're like I'm gonna kill
you that's considered a threat threat
yeah that's illegal it's the same thing
then right well it's also in the context
of the argument right so they're saying
that the action made the neighbor feel
extremely threatened and that's why they
called 9-1-1 and so they're saying that
they've had arguments obviously it's not
gonna happen in a healthy neighborly
relationship and then so they're saying
that because of this neighbor being so
argumentative with them they had to
install our security camera so he [ __ ]
with all the neighbors I mean that's
what they're saying you know like this
[Laughter]
every day wakes up in the morning he's
miming
boom boom that's too threatening now
don't worry should have done is you you
do the shovel like knows how to use all
his object object work or what if the
neighbors pyramids blinds and he's still
digging later that night just getting
accurate hole at six feet of dirt right
there get some lemonade he's like he's
like the mimic son is just [ __ ] hot
and the next day he's building a casket
holding nails in the mouth really
committed to this like I won't make no
gun gestures but you go die yeah I'm
just doing my poor thing we're scared of
that guy that's like committing Todd how
do you do this then dig the grave all
like oh you're very unstable I would
love to see them take me to court don't
for doing all those mines yeah
in the boot video footage I don't see
that I think I'm more scared I had
yesterday this guy on the Hollins are
taking a bill like asking like three
months then he's like oh I'm getting to
the wall some nice rosy feeling waning
painting with like his mentally he can
get it done in a weekend because
otherwise he's got to go to work and
then come back and keep working this is
a wicked project yeah but the casket guy
you know he'd oh he'll he'll he has a
disciplined for it so it's like kind of
scarier cuz you know he doesn't quit
stop that's super scary you took off a
day of working like nah man I gotta
catch up mines his [ __ ] driving the
word and he's like working at the
factory ship
he's work he's working on it yeah when
he drives up I totally pictured all that
I was so yeah this man he's 64 years old
by the way Steven and so they were
saying that so he was saying that at the
time the female neighbor that was like
he was arguing with oh he did that to a
female so she he said that she had both
she had given him the finger with both
hands that's when he ended up doing the
gun oh man I think it's not the same you
know [ __ ] you just you gotta do [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you yeah yeah you gotta go
eyeball fists straight to gun is too
aggressive yeah have you seen the [ __ ]
you fight in New York what are you
saying that it heightened because of
that because she goes like this he goes
like that like this
oh she look at that those are sighs yeah
he should have been like like this with
his middle of something and yeah like
it's like during like oh yeah and then
they push themselves but oh yeah and
they [ __ ] themselves up yes and then
it's like yeah it's like Jim Carrey in
my lair they [ __ ] themselves up yeah
they get in a fight with themselves what
I'm gonna do to you
but then this would be suicide right
yeah yeah that's like
damn at the end but you just said I'm
gonna hate this thing you're playing
your own head but it's a gesture towards
them I hear gonna do it to them oh yeah
and this is we both died participated
and he was like she was like she comes
in with a tank and [ __ ] a core unit
carnage is like I make sound effects
next time so you know that's for like
thank you that would help me yeah thank
you
we're gonna be neighbors an honor if
that's the extent of violence that I got
up to though that would make me really
happy where it's just like everybody
like it's like fighting with their
neighbors but all in minds no it
actually gets her if I'd be like yeah
that sounds like a lot of fun like yeah
let's put out a sword sword fighting
lightsabers even better now I'm using
the force on you I'm token you never
might be like no no no fantasy [ __ ] no
superhero skin no superhero only real
world [ __ ] two cars they're gonna fight
over that [ __ ] sister cars there's a
baby like with me we're slave trade into
cars like full-grown burn the city down
he's like kind of finding himself would
it be threatening if he just went like
this and didn't pull the trigger
ah yeah because I saw him pulled the
trigger and I wonder if that makes it
worse like this that's not my house in
my house inside my house and someone was
like that I'd probably pull out a real
gun and point at them but I'm gonna let
them know like if you are threatening me
to kill me I will shew back Oh
fake gun to a real gun fire yeah because
that gesture makes me think he's gonna
go in his house and grab a gun grab a
[ __ ] gun yeah some kids standing
outside boys house one day with a water
gun
[Laughter]
yeah so they're saying that so Stephen
was arguing that the hand gesture didn't
create a hazardous or physically
offensive condition and he said that he
didn't mean to cause public alarm and
that there was there wasn't really any
harm does just like come on guys it's
not even loaded
I just want to scare her I mean cocking
I just I didn't even shoot in her
direction it was a warning shot I just
shot it off as a warning I know that's
right now look quick but the Superior
Court of Pennsylvania found that the
gesture served no legitimate purpose and
recklessly risk provoking a dangerous
altercation so he was ordered to pay
$100 fine the menacing is invoking a
dangerous altercation oh that's the
correct I guess I mean that's what they
said so he has a record now for this
history you got to tell you about we got
a record for James broom for what
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm also playful
[Music]
[Music]